[Music]
Michael bublé's three-year-old son Noah
is battling cancer what would you say is
the hardest part about being a father uh
just that you're scared all the time
because you love them so much that you
can't ever ever think of a world without
them I think that's a real of every
single parent out there they know what
I'm talking about Michael and his wife
Lois Anna revealed the heartbreaking
news in a statement on Facebook writing
quote we are devastated about the recent
cancer diagnosis of our oldest son Noah
who is currently undergoing treatment in
the u.s. we have always been very vocal
about the importance of family and the
love we have for our children
Lois Anna and I have put our careers on
hold in order to devote all our time and
attention to helping Noah get well at
this difficult time we ask only for your
prayers and respect for our privacy we
have a long journey in front of us and
hope that with the support of family
friends and fans around the world we
will win this battle God willing